Wat what wat ze happening here
in the U.S and why I think you know Look
man things are in Looking two Pretty We
got the story from twitch.com biden
Administration has disgust man dating
vaccines for interstage Travel It
ministration is reported looking for
Waste to make life more on comfortable
for Those the night complete The apart
quote One sewer measures so Just man
dating vaccines for Ender State Travel
or Changing Had A few vs treatment for
Those War on Wax neated and become Mel
of cover Help me does Cost that
ministration worried they Would Be two
Paul Rising at this time and it minute
station official Set the Ender State
Travel wax nation requirement with not
under consideration at the moment That's
not to say They want Be implemented In
The Future as Public opinion Can't in
this  to shift tord requirem vaccinations
as a means to restore normal seedor Port
ads I think This is a big ask you know
you for me with big Ask
If for some Reason Public  opinion Just
chips don't think Soccer Now You Know
What happen if they implemented man Day
vaccine mandates First a Travel all the
people becancettem for Medical purposis
curtain Travel Be An sandley with Just
Fall apart institutions because You've
got in early Where right now  where the
Try State so we got a cross the State
Borders to go to the Storm I wanna milk we
got a we go to Different Stay So What
happens under Like You Got A stop but a
Checkpoint The braid Would Be clutted
Howard Checkpoint peop
Where we  are the states had rolls that
you could not leave the state and if you
there you are the courantine of the air
so you could give you a car in drive
there are some examptions for people who
live with a certain man of certain myles
of a border of  A State so Where we are
was like We Are exped We were All Out To
but There Was A someone I was talking to
upon mastures We Wanna Have Them on the
show on this is the Problem was when
they Drive that the story to get  Milk
The after drive a Cross The Border And
then May could get stuped or agreed In
Love they have the quantine so They work
in turned like a Fine leaving Come Back
There gonna Force make a Lockdown I
can't Leave The House For to weeks I
can't even gonna Store so They are Force
to go for the arrow in the round St
die stinkt have happened
People at the Borders some places did
have
Cross The Board With Us
concidere Conor MC en go back to go
back to the end I Guess  some More that
thing Here Public Health as a Just A
Vacation for Whatever You Wanna Do
interns have impousing a Third a Public
Out And National security Grounds are
going to be the ground That are used
intensely or not to viserated
everything I'm In we'  ve seen with
chronovires OBS with a Center Shape
associated with it and that government
by proxy via Big taq aubergine First A
Moment you see it with Walking everyone
Down but Wedding social Justice Warriors
Out Into The Streets
Walking Down place  s When Look in a free
Society the rests people where the
rescue and the acting way If or free
Society but quirity were increasing When
Nothing Can I Violet God winslow for
second You know that sees claim jois
People Carey types and now Was One Of
The Reasons  They Need it to Mark
People
yeah Public Health is a really Easy and
easy way for atarance to get in because
people are Scared of disease you want to
People That's the whole thing I will say
this you know when you watch movies like
We Are you  read book 1984 when you watch
this Nightmare this tell me a movies
when you want you for Vendetta did you
think that When A Four tering his and
came to your front door There were Being
know excuse like we When You See These
movies Words like There's The  Resistance
And that Just live in this Nightmare
distopia do you think that One Day The
chancelers Set Up Inside Oh By the way
I'm Not The Dictator and where Fashion
Travel It is in your face but they have
an excuse  Fort so People Gladly drop to
There knees and say please State Keep me
Safe and Take My freedoms from mecable
Never Anything from Benjamin Franklin
Those Would Give Up Their Freedom Or
Without Essential Liberty Is For A
Little Bit Of Security Deserve Nation
Will Loose balls I really  River Point on
your perspective on this statement About
what they Could Be Doing It They I
thought for sing that was that It's a
Flex feels like a big military Flex like
you know We Could shut Everything Down
all the Borders Ghana and it's like
There Holding Mad  over overheads They
want to but it is over 10 Window Shift
Yes mix What is proceed this Reason of
all six Months from Now what's Crazy
Today and if then to
two weeks This World a current
and what we Never Walk down her country
ever Before it certain  with Now for the
spirit of Times for Any Reason What sure
ever the power grams Have Been Tour
Point so In Your Face And The en Walk
you was architect as pupper Companion
chips  but There someone quote
constitution I mean Aquarius and what
the paper to Sprint anymore It's Trump
If Public campions It's What's the Law
What's In Love With It Don't
worry Because We have get Know It's not
hot wheel Whatever but it's top Times
and you then  You're was Worth of Nothing
but not a free country I think The Law
is mostly would Nothing I think Culture
as Everything There's Search on the box
with Talk to Valentine's show Like You
Knows that There is As Old Block You Can
Get Words like
this  trivia Thing and I Will I You Can't
put an apple Pine And The Windows 1
thurs Days you can you can't use your
Garden hoes at 3 PM on a Monday after
noon and a Full Moon And You're like
what it is  weird Lost never getting
Force but Around The books because
culturally we say All That subsered know
what do that so even know the Locked you
can't We Never got With A Bed and
There's a tunnor really Crazy Lost on
about you was super chat 'em  Ah
super chat Was All The Time S  o What
happens is We got a constitution but if
vaken Just Keep Pushing to the point
wear clearly beyond the constition What A
What happens Now is they say Or Not
violetting You Right by shutting Down
your speech on a private Platform we
have private platform is the  only Place
place of This Is The Diamond plays
happens Where not Violin Right to Bear
Arms by Telling You Can't Own specific
Fire Arms you can Always have a single
loaded you know Ball Action no Whatever
There's a When I violetting in Third of
anarch by  manding you How is People
because Only some Of Those People are
soldiers When I've I Living your Force A
Man right with searchy bears I smell put
And that is increasing Way Where we are
It is Wall and also that was selective
for your pide and  if you a Five a lot to
One person One Way and Another personer
Way then you have no raw for Double
Standard Justice means no Just so what
to do
and Law by Light is the Century Whatever
the State is Goes And narco  tierne
To The Dark And The Piano the suveren
people at the End of the day robuy Why
is oh we're going up with a National
security on the box Which says and they
have really Have This Intelligence and
National security was you know If You'  re
companies doing in sensitive information
orph the State Need it be Instagram about
thing to as and tableware As An apparates
and also Like The Water me in Whatever
is one paper doesn't actually Mean
Anything The endo Day It's What the
Roller says It is That's  It's a Quartier
Right so hear the last you can see like
januar sexas rating they will I minutes
People are in solitary there Getting
Months and Prison for many of literally
Just try to trespassing someone this
People There's one video of like an old
Lady Walking through the  way Cup Hold to
open for her and cheese Getting Charge
to I come on man If I go to building a
coups like Right This Way Sorry I be
like cool not transpass
So You have right now the government
Wellingto  n Force and he Thank you Ball
stretch Power meanwile Active Looking
going Burn Down your business with imdy
because that narco turné they Only it it
's lock man
in je midden Fallen reference it feels
to me
friend
and I live
The People It is justins of power to
self There is so much on hope and with
Technology you can The carbon Dark Side
from Here The passive that on the platy
A micrafting with the U Can you know
Iron furtallize The Ocean's to regrar
the planet in the re Bloom the Fish
population you can Shadow chorel  and all
grocer the same Time the real quarteries
you can see bomb deserts to play tree
like 100 is a Millions of Trees per Day
There is so much It's so Easy If We Know
What to do and what to do you did my
favorite terrorforming methodos Imagine
Lot of really Great things That We Can
Do they have the plant my favorite this
building casino in The Desert yes
old out Amazing They clouds there now
that Grass They Bring It On All In The
import water and F  ood and People Fly
There and They drain Better With more
water and the System and a water of
apparate ja work mechanically like
terraforming Las Vegas That's really
interesting langward checking Out this
clip from the timcast irrell podcast if
you wanna see the fold show come back to
this Channel
youtube.com/teamcaste areal Monday
through Friday 8pm Where You Can Leave
commands and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
Don't Forget to like share subscribe and
if you want Exclusive members Only can't
sachmans you  can you Arrows go to them
cast.com Become A number and we even and
fall bonus episodes Thanks bring it now
I was the one next time